[Musique]
bonsoir à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
pour faire le point sur l'actualité de
la semaine dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition la finale
de la troisième édition du concours
robotique à l'estaca 300 collégiens
événements ou participer à ce challenge
le principe construire un robot durant
l'année scolaire la remise des prix elle
à suivre dans cette édition
à quelques jours du baccalauréat nous
recevons delphine remaniée elle est
professeur d'anglais et représentante
snes fsu des yvelines révision gestion
de la dernière semaine elle vous donnera
des conseils pour se préparer à l'examen
nous évoquerons si la réforme du bac et
la plateforme parcours sup
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur la visite du ministre de
l'éducation nationale à versailles
retour aussi sur la pétition lancée par
les élus de la verrière sur la
rénovation de la gare et sur le salon
santé bien-être de saint quentin en
yvelines avant de développer ses titres
cette information pourrait vous
intéresser
n'oubliez pas de faire le plein
d'essence dans votre véhicule
les agricultures ont prévu de bloquer 13
raffineries et dépôts de carburant à
l'appel de la fnsea et des jeunes
agriculteurs à partir de dimanche soir
le site de coignières est concerné par
ce blocage
une mobilisation pour protester contre
la politique agricole du gouvernement et
la signature des accords de libre
échange
autre mobilisation et vos boîtes aux
lettres resteront vides à partir du
jeudi 14 juin
la fédération cgt des facteurs appellent
à une grève illimitée dans les yvelines
ils protestent contre la réorganisation
de leurs conditions de travail
une modification qui pourrait notamment
entraîner des suppressions de postes ou
de tournée selon le syndicat les
facteurs avaient déjà organisé une
journée de mobilisation le 29 mai
dernier à la une de l'actualité 300
collégiens des yvelines ont appris à
modéliser
créer programmer un robot en l'espace de
neuf mois
il participait ce vendredi à la finale
du challenge robotique devant un jury
les classes retenues ont présenté leur
projet est réalisé une démonstration sur
un parcours
l'école d'ingénieurs estaca à montigny
le bretonneux accueillir cet événement
un reportage de nicolas kirillovitch à
seulement 15 ans arthur est déjà un chef
de projet qui n'hésite pas à prendre la
parole pour défendre son travail
puis tous les groupes qui ne participait
pas à la finale nous ont gentiment prêté
leur leurs éléments du décor avec ses
camarades de 3e b il présente le robot
qu'il élabore depuis plusieurs mois sa
classe participe cette année au
challenge robotique un concours
départemental dédié à la programmation
[Musique]
la décision évidemment on rentre sur une
sur quelque chose qui est relativement
simplifiée par rapport aux enjeux de la
robotique mais je pense que l'idée ce
site inspiré ces élèves là peut-être se
piquer leur curiosité et si c'est un
sujet qui leur pied qu'ils puissent eux
approfondir mieux comprendre thématique
de cette troisième édition la
sylviculture les élèves devaient créer
un robot capable de reconnaître et
planter des arbres sur un circuit
uniquement créés pour l'occasion
[Musique]
il faut savoir que mes élèves ont
travaillé sont venus travailler sur le
projet à peu près trois heures par
semaine sur leur temps libre c'est à
dire après après le repas entre 4 heures
et 14 heures
trois fois par semaine cette semaine
encore certains élèves sont venus à la
fin des cours ou le mercredi après midi
pour finaliser les derniers détails
travailler en équipe ou développer les
connaissances des élèves en informatique
le concours avait surtout une visée
pédagogique certaines vocations se sont
aussi révélés
moi j'aimerais bien en faire mon métier
plus tard peut-être et toi tu vois ça tu
as plus pourquoi c'était sympa la
programmation je pense que je vais
m'orienter par là dans l'avenir donc ça
permet de découvrir aussi un petit peu
pour la première fois cette année des
élèves en situation de handicap ont
participé au challenge robotique
fort de son succès une quatrième édition
sera programmée c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour les révisions du
baccalauréat près de dix neuf lycéens
yvelinois avons commencé les épreuves le
18 juin prochain et pour parler de ce
sujet nous accueillons delphine rhmani
vous êtes professeur d'anglais au lycée
léonard de vinci à saint germain en laye
et vous êtes aussi co secrétaire
départemental du snes fsu 78 points ce
soir bonsoir
alors le snes fsu je rappel c'est le
syndicat national des enseignements de
second degré collèges et lycées le
second dresser les collèges et les
lycées
alors comment on va comment les élèves
vont se préparer pour cette dernière
semaine qu'est ce que vous conseiller de
faire alors c'est très variable suivant
les établissements il ya encore des
établissements qui font cours donc je
n'en conseille évidemment d'aller en
classe jusqu'au bout et de profiter de
la présence de leurs de leur enseigner
de leurs enseignants pour réviser et
puis pour les lycéens qui n'ont plus
cours
est il donc il reste à la maison qui
font leurs révisions tout seul une bonne
manière d'organiser ces révisions c'est
de faire un planning sur la semaine par
demi-journée et de réviser chaque
matière un petit peu chaque matin où
chaque après-midi alors vous dites y en
a qui font des plannings c'est un peu
chacun sa méthode y en a qui révise à
partir des cours directement il y en a
certains qui ont fait des fiches pendant
toute l'année
réviser en groupe un seul au cdi
ou chez soi qu'est ce que c'est quoi la
meilleure manière en fait alors n'y a
pas de meilleure manière vous l'avez dit
un petit peu dans votre question
évidemment ça dépend ça dépend à la fois
de la personnalité de l'élève mais aussi
de la discipline qui ne va qu il va
réviser le conseil par contre que je
donnerais moi c'est que la maintenance
ce n'est pas le moment d'acquérir des
choses nouvelles s'ils ont travaillé
toute l'année si l'on était régulier ces
moments de reprendre leur cours de
relire les fiches qui l'ont fait tout au
long de l'année et éventuellement de
travailler à plusieurs
s'ils ont un petit groupe d'élèves avec
certains élèves qui ont des forces et
danton des faiblesses et qui peuvent
s'entraider
voilà et de faire tout ça calmement de
garder un rythme de vie régulier et de
voile à ne pas se fatiguer la dernière
semaine avant l'examen
alors je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur d'anglais donc dans ce lycée
léonard de vinci à saint-germain-en-laye
ckoi l'épreuve d'anglais
en quoi consiste-t-elle lors du bac
alors vaste question les élèves ont déjà
passé plusieurs épreuves orales qu'on
appelle maintenant en cours d'année et
il leur reste maintenant une épreuve
écrite qui consiste pour toutes les
séries en textes avec des questions
auxquelles ils doivent répondre qu'ils
portent sur le texte donc c'est la
compréhension de texte et puis une
expression écrite dont la longueur peut
varier selon les séries alors quelles
sont les difficultés dans cette épreuve
qu'il faut surmonter donner cependant
cette matière notamment alors 10 est à
dire la consigne ce très souvent les
élèves perdent des points presque du mal
de la consigne bien relire le texte
plusieurs fois absolument appuyer ses
réponses sur le texte ne pas extrapoler
puisque c'est de la compréhension de
texte on leur demande pas leur avis mais
d'avoir bien compris le texte de bien
gérer son temps bien sûr de garder à peu
près la moitié du temps pour
l'expression écrite l'expression écrite
c'est là où on peut s'exprimer c'est ça
voilà c'est ça il s'agit de l'expression
personnelle ça peut être plutôt un sujet
d'imagination ou plutôt un sujet à un
petit peu argumentatif
voilà c'est ça dépend des séries et puis
du thème du texte en général
l'expression écrite est en lien avec le
texte alors l'épreuve d'anglais aura
lieu le mercredi pour ceux qui ont
choisi anglais lv1 langues vivantes
première et puis après donc la lv2 c'est
sur les jours qui reste qu'à la
philosophie le lundi l'histoire
géographie le mardi ça c'est pour le bac
général
d'autres matières viennent après pour en
fonction des des filières qu'on a choisi
au total c'est plus de 20 heures
d'épreuve est ce que c'est pas trop pour
des élèves des lycéens en une semaine
alors c'est beaucoup c'est vrai mais
c'est un petit peu aussi le jeu d'examen
c'est à dire c'est un petit peu une
épreuve sportive aux siens il faut il
faut s'entraîner à pouvoir enchaîner les
épreuves et a montré qu'on est capable
de maîtriser beaucoup beaucoup de
discipline et des programmes qui sont
lourds je crois que ça fait partie du
jeu l'examen que c'est une bonne chose
c'est une bonne expérience aussi pour
les jeunes alors un conseil aussi qu'on
peut donner est ce que vous conseiller
de réviser pendant la semaine de
l'examen ou est ce que justement on doit
se reposer et se détendre entre les
épreuves alors g litre est absolument à
tout prix les révisions dernière minute
moi ce que je conseille aux élèves sont
à la fois pendant les révisions et
pendant la période d'examen
c'est d'avoir un rythme de vie régulier
bien manger bien dormir un comme des
sportifs avoir éventuellement une petite
activité sportive mais pas trop
fatiguant pour se relaxer et penser à
autre chose et si éventuellement ça les
rassure de faire quelque chose relire
tranquillement des choses qui sont déjà
maîtrisé voilà tranquillement dans un
canapé ou même sur son be1 voilà mais
surtout ne pas ajouter de stress
supplémentaire la veille d'un examen je
reviens sur cette semaine d'examens très
rythmé très intense l'édition 2000 21 du
baccalauréat donc c'est la réforme qui
est prévu par le gouvernement ce serait
40% de notation en contrôle continu à
partir des résultats de première et de
terminale puis 60% à partir d'un examen
qui comprendrait quatre épreuves
est-ce que ça permettrait pas justement
d'alléger ce rythme et d'alléger
l'épreuve finale du baccalauréat alors
en fait nous vous le savez sans doute au
snes fsu on est très critique vis-à-vis
de cette réforme parce qu'en réalité le
ministère communique sur le nombre
d'épreuves qui doit diminuer alors qu'en
réalité elles vont se multiplier puisque
les élèves vont être évaluée en
permanence en première et en terminale
donc on aboutit finalement à plus d'une
vingtaine d'épreuves alors
qu'actuellement il ya un peu moins d'une
dizaine
autre sujet sur lequel vous êtes
mobilisés c'est avec les étudiants
notamment cesser la contestation sur la
plateforme d'orientation parcours sup
alors au niveau national si 115 mille
élèves ont reçu au moins une proposition
de formation actuellement en études
supérieures ça fait ça représente 60
perso 76 % des élèves un taux inférieur
aux 80 % de lycéens l'an dernier avec la
plateforme apb admission postbac
quelle est la situation dans les
yvelines par rapport à cette plateforme
par coups reçus parce que les qu'elle
est elle est dans quel lycée est ce que
vous avez des exemples de lycées dans
les yvelines
oui alors je vais pouvoir d'autres
questions mais auparavant un petit un
petit préambule nous le ministère
communique sur le nombre d'élèves qui
ont au moins une proposition mais il
faut être très prudent avec ces chiffres
parce qu'en réalité ce n'est pas parce
que les candidats ont une proposition
que cette proposition leur convient
puisque ça peut être leur dernier veut
sur la liste qui l'ont fait en cas la
paire sécurité est par contre il ya
beaucoup d'élèves qui ont des
propositions mais en effet qui qui ne
conviendra à ce qu'il souhaite
réellement
par exemple si on prend le cas du lycée
de la plaine 2 nov la trappe
on voit que par exemple en terminale l
environ 50 % des élèves ont accepté une
proposition et les 50% restants n'ont
pas accepté de propositions ça veut dire
soit qui sont en attente sur un veau qui
souhaitent vraiment soin qu'ils ont été
refusées par tout ce qui est le cas par
exemple pour la terminale l 2 25% de la
classe des propositions quand même voilà
ils ont des propositions mais s'ils le
désirent ils ont pas accepter ça veut
dire qui les attendent en fait question
sur listes d'attentes pour une autre
formation qu'ils préfèrent et est donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils n'acceptent pas les
propositions qui leur ont fait qu'est-ce
qu'ils attendent d'aller vers quelque
chose qui leur plaît plus vous avez une
autre situation vous souhaitiez comparé
notamment avec un autre lycée oui alors
tout à fait c'est intéressant parce que
si on compare les chiffres avec ceux du
lycée hoche à versailles 94 8% des
élèves au moins une proposition et 21
21 % sont en attente donc on voit ici il
ya une forte disparité entre les
chiffres puisque les élèves du lycée
hoche semble avoir mieux passer
l'épreuve de parcours sud si j'ose dire
et donc ce qu'on voit par là c'est qu'en
réalité le lycée d'origine a un fort
pouvoir discriminant dans la sélection
au moment de perdre conçu les
professeurs vous le confirme que ce
phénomène que vous évoquez mais alors on
a des exemples qui sont d'autres
départements où par exemple une élève de
terminale s qui a 18 de moyenne générale
et qui n'est pas pris sur ses prises sur
ses premiers voeux alors delphine
remaniée à rester avec nous on passe au
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
ils rentreront au collège à la rentrée
prochaine mais pour le moment ils ont de
la lecture pour les vacances 450 élèves
franciliens de cm2 ont reçu un
exemplaire des fables de la fontaine un
cadeau remis par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer re mardi dernier à l'orangerie
du château de versailles
un reportage de camille lambert l'a dit
il faut que je me venge là dessus au
fond des forêts le loup lot porte et
puis le mange sans autre forme de procès
jean de la fontaine
la raison du plus fort est toujours la
meilleure c'est en tout cas ce que
montre le loup et l'agneau écrit en 1668
par jean de la fontaine à l'orangerie du
château de versailles 450 élèves de cm2
étaient réunis pour recevoir un
exemplaire de ces fables une initiative
menée par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
les fables de la fontaine ont quelque
chose d'éternel elle d'abord elle
fonctionne à tous les âges c'est à dire
ça plaît aux enfants aux adolescents aux
adultes
et puis elles nous disent quelque chose
d'éternel puisqu'il ya toujours une
morale des fables de la fontaine
et puis il ya une forme des fables de la
fontaine qui tout simplement nous mène
au beau c'est l'école du bien du vrai du
beausset sont les trois notions qui sont
derrière tous les toutes les
transmissions de savoirs et toutes les
transmissions de valeur et donc la
fontaine fait partie de ces écrivains
qui d'une certaine façon rassemble tous
à un recueil enrichie par les dessins de
l'illustrateur johann sfar auteur du
chat du rabbin l'objectif donner goût à
la lecture l'idée c'est d'offrir un
livre illustré pour amener à mener une
peut-être une petite habitude qui est
mon ami ni scolaire ni éducative qui à
un moment de liberté où on s'approprie
un texte par les fables de la fontaine
ça me semble essentiel parce que ce sont
de petites chansons elles sont très
ironique elles ont un aspect
un petit peu provocant on est là ça peut
critiquer ou le pouvoir ou la famille ou
les proches d'en face et s'est fait pour
se moquer de ce qui nous entoure et voir
les travers des uns et des autres j'aime
bien j'aime bien les dessins c'est
émouvant
il est bien et les dessins et son bo5
d'une belle et sans moi j'en ai lancé en
2010 est un livre pour les vacances a
permis cette année à huit cent mille
élèves de cm2 de toute la france
d'obtenir leurs ouvrages
une opération qui sera renouvelée tous
les ans avec un dessinateur différent
pour refermer cette page l'éducation les
professeurs et les élèves du lycée 17
mar de maurepas ont protesté ce mardi
devant l'établissement ils se mobilisent
contre la suppression de l'option sport
à la rentrée 2010 neuf une mesure
décidée par l'éducation nationale elle
concerne 120 lycées en france dont trois
dans l'académie de versailles
un reportage de michael idron ses
professeurs de paix s du lycée 17 mar
joue peut être le match le plus
important de leur carrière brassard noir
autour du bras ils ont organisé ce mardi
5 juin une veillée funèbre
objectif protester contre la suppression
de l'option sport dans leur
établissement leur rentrée 2010 9 voulue
par l'éducation nationale on pouvait pas
se permettre de rien faire parce qu'on
pense à nos élèves on pense aussi à
notre équipe de direction qui nous a
toujours soutenus au niveau du projet
d'établissement
on pense à tous ces airs on pense à on
pense à tous les parents qui sont aussi
investir la spécialité instauré depuis
1999 par l'établissement permet aux
élèves d'ajouter cinq heures de sport en
plus par semaine en second des quatre en
première et en terminale
cette année près d'une centaine d'élèves
ont choisi cette option donc un vrai
gâchis parce que je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient mesure est un petit peu là le
la perte
la perte et l'expérience que ça peut
apporter aussi bien pour accéder à une
filière staps pour les élèves qui
sortent avec le bac ou pour des
simplement pour leur épanouissement
personnel et enrichissement pour pour le
bac pour les points que ça peut apporter
au bac
d'autres actions pourraient être menées
dans les prochaines semaines le match
n'est peut-être pas encore terminée dale
chaîne roumanie on voit vos collègues de
professeurs d eps réagir par rapport à
cette suppression
quel retour vous avez au niveau global
parce que là c'est vraiment concentré
sur le lycée 17 mar mais globalement
dans les yvelines qu'elle retrouvera les
de vos collègues alors sur les édiles
j'ai pas de chiffres par contre ce que
je sais c'est que au niveau national ces
120 établissements qui ont cette option
eps
donc ça veut dire qu'à l'échelle de la
france c'est une option qui est
relativement rare donc qui ne coûte pas
si cher que ça à l'échelle du budget de
l'éducation nationale et qui pourtant
est menacé alors l'autre sujet aussi qui
a fait un peu on en a parlé cette
semaine c'est le vote à l'assemblée
nationale de l'interdiction des
portables dans les écoles et les
collèges
alors les collèges c'est le sanguinaire
vous êtes représentante de la snes donc
qu'il ça concerne le second degré votre
position sur ce point
alors je dirais que c'est un petit peu
un effet d annonce médiatique parce
qu'en réalité les téléphones portables
sont déjà interdits dans la plupart des
établissements on a un ministre qui
maîtrise parfaitement toutes les toutes
les comment les arcanes de la
communication médiatique et nous ce
qu'on pense surtout c'est que c'est un
petit peu la poudre aux yeux et que
pendant qu'on parle de l'usagé des
téléphones portables
on parle pas de ce qu'il faudrait faire
vraiment c'est à dire une véritable
éducation aux médias qui permettent aux
jeunes d'être armé face à tous les
problèmes d'addiction qui peuvent avoir
mais aussi ceux dont on ne parle pas et
qui est beaucoup plus préoccupant c'est
toutes les difficultés auxquels se
confronte nos collèges nos collègues de
collège au quotidien dans l'exercice de
leur métier
delphine romani merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur notre plateau donc je le
rappelle vous êtes professeur d'anglais
au lycée léonard de vinci à saint
germain en laye et vous êtes co
secrétaire départemental du snes fsu 78
merci à vous et bon week-end puis merci
bon week end à vous une page économie le
réseau entreprendre
il a récompensé 16 nouveaux
entrepreneurs c'était mardi au palais
des congrès de versailles
des créations de projets à des reprises
d'entreprises tous ont permis de créer
ou de maintenir des emplois sur le
territoire
camille lambert s'est rendu à cette
cérémonie pour découvrir les lauréats
vous pouvez changer le monde en
changeant de langue et cette phrase
c'est la devise de thomas journel qui
lui a valu la création de sa boulangerie
à versailles en septembre 2010 est du
pain bio mais aussi un lieu de partage
avec des cours de yoga et des
expositions culturelles à l'est ou vers
un lieu international un lieu polyvalent
un lieu où on fait des rencontres où on
peut se retrouver à n'importe quelle
heure avec des activités adaptées par
rapport à ce qu'on vient chercher donc
le matin il ya un petit déj
le midi un plat du jour le soir veut
boire un verre un concept qui a séduit
le réseau entreprendre yvelines
thomas journel fait partie des nouveaux
entrepreneurs de la promotion 2010 est
les seize lauréats ont été récompensés
par l'association au palais des congrès
de versailles
il ya une aide financière nos lauréats
perçoivent environ trente quarante mille
euros d aides financières qui vont
surtout leur permettre d'avoir un effet
de levier vis-à-vis de nos banques
partenaires
ce qui est très très important c'est
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement qui
ayant mis en place avec un chef
d'entreprise en activité la plupart du
temps qui va suivre le lauréat
pendant à peu près de deux années une
assistance pour concrétiser son projet
avec ce dispositif longue liu a pu créer
sa marque de souliers en mars et voit
déjà plus loin
notre rêve c'était de faire des souliers
à la main par du pas des souris à la
main comme comme on faisait il ya
plusieurs siècles on peut grandir avant
avant avant trois ans peut 3 d'ici 3 à 5
ans compte est grossir l'équipe est
embauché 3 à 5 personnes
seul ombre au tableau soulevées par la
vice-présidente de la région et marraine
de la promotion alexandra dublanche
encore trop peu de femmes font partie de
l' aventure surtout les entrepreneurs
qui sont accompagnés par des structures
comme réseau entreprendre et à 39 % de
femmes nous logiquement on veut
atteindre 50% de femmes et c'est
l'objectif toutes ces structures les
finances on leur a dit maintenant ont
mené cet objectif 50 % depuis ses débuts
en 2011 réseau entreprendre yvelines a
permis de créer ou de sauvegarder 1400
emplois sur le téléphone on poursuit 7,8
l'hebdo avec cette information de la
préfecture des migrants ont été évacués
dès campement du canal saint martin et
la paix de la porte des poissonniers à
paris ce lundi 4 juin
parmi eux 160 ont été accueillis dans
les yvelines 65 personnes ont été
installés à luz yens 55 abonnés des 40 à
saint germain en laye une situation de
temporaire avant un examen complet de
leur situation
depuis le début de la semaine ils se
mobilisent devant la gare de la verrière
les élus de la commune et du
mesnil-saint-denis font signer une
pétition leurs revendications la
construction d'un ascenseur pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite du côté de
la verrière de la gare
des travaux qui ne figure pas encore
dans la rénovation
du site la rénovation pardon globale du
site
reportage plus de 600 signatures en
trois jours pour la pétition intitulée
égalité d'accès à la gare de la verrière
une égalité demandé par les élus de la
commune et du mesnil-saint-denis la
construction des ascenseurs et déjà
prévu du côté de maurepas et sur les
deux quais de la gare du côté de la
verrière l'installation de cet
équipement n'est pas assurée un
investissement de plus d'un million
d'euros par ascenseur
comme tout le monde à peu près d'accord
que il faut d ascenseur pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite le problème
il est financier la sncf elle elle voit
l'entretien qu'elle aura porté
au niveau des ascenseurs donc
je peux comprendre mais en même temps
nous de ce côté là on a un vrai besoin
le mesnil saint denis est aussi
concernée selon la mairie près de 3000
habitants de la commune sont
susceptibles de fréquenter la gare de la
verrière des usagers qui viennent aussi
de la vallée de chevreuse prendre ce
train à descendre avec une valise ou
bien avec une poussette et des enfants
eh bien ça relève de l'exploit donc il
est absolument anormal que aujourd'hui à
notre époque faire une rénovation de
gares sans prévoir la mise en
accessibilité pour une grande partie de
la population puisque je pense que les
flux de ce côté dépasse les deux tiers
des usagers de la garde
bah tout simplement c'est pas normal
selon saint quentin en yvelines
l'installation de cet ascenseur devrait
être portée par la sncf une version que
conteste l'entreprise ferroviaire en
attente de nouvelles informations sur le
financement
ces travaux s'inscrivent dans la
rénovation du pôle gare de la verrière
un investissement global des
collectivités de 16 millions d'euros
des travaux prévus entre 2019 et 2022
restons à saint quentin en yvelines une
quarantaine de professionnels et
d'associations étaient réunis hier pour
le étaient réunis cette semaine pour le
premier salon de la santé et du
bien-être organisé par l'agglomération
un événement mis en place avec l'aide de
l'institut de promotion de la santé
500 personnes ont fait le déplacement à
la ferme du manière reportage à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines +2 50% des
médecins généralistes vont partir à la
retraite dans les prochaines années pour
pallier la désertification médicale sur
son territoire l'agglomération a signé
son deuxième contrat local de santé avec
ses partenaires notamment l' agence
régionale de santé et la préfecture des
yvelines travailler vraiment l'offre de
soins former des médecins faire en sorte
que des médecins qui les jeunes médecins
les étudiants en médecine de
l'université qu'ils puissent rester sur
le territoire qu'ils puissent exercer
sur le territoire car
centaine de professionnels de santé qui
va falloir faire venir sur le territoire
dans les cinq 5 à 7 ans à venir
une signature qui se tenait à l'occasion
du premier salon du bien-être organisé
par l'agglomération
une quarantaine d'exposants étaient
présents à la ferme du manet comme cette
maison des géants pour prévenir les
risques domestiques ou cet atelier pour
réaliser son propre dentifrice l'argile
rêvant d'être un petit peu et j'en
mettais beaucoup en argile blanche de
carbonate de soude quelques gouttes
d'huiles essentielles et un peu d'eau
des ingrédients naturels
on utilise tous au quotidien que ce soit
ça avant shampoing maquillage dentifrice
bresse et des produits concise au
quotidien et idc d'essayer de creuser un
peu
voilà on les utilise mais qu'est-ce qui
a concrètement à l'intérieur développer
la connaissance sur
le domaine de la prévention pour les
enfants pour les sensibiliser
sensibilisés à l'environnement et puis
la santé très important selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
plupart des maladies chroniques comme le
diabète ou certains cancers seraient
directement liées à nos modes de vie
pour cette première édition ce salon a
attiré plus de 500 visiteurs avant de
refermer cette édition je vous rappelle
donc le blocage du dépôt de carburant à
coignières par les agriculteurs
alors n'oubliez pas de faire le plein
d'essence ce week end
et puis autre information c'est jeudi
prochain les facteurs entameront leur
grève illimitée pour protester contre
une modification de leurs conditions de
travail
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver henry pelé cette émission sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile télé 78 retour dans le retour de
l'information dans le set suite journal
à 18 heures lundi
d'ici là passez un excellent week end
[Musique]